Vì muốn người trong cú mọi giá đình của một phụ nước và bà trẻ em đã thiệt mạng trong vụ lực tuyền
trên xong ngàn phố, đoạn qua giá xân kim một tình hả tính.
Vụ tên nạc sẽ giá và chêu qua trong gì phải quay chơi,
muốn mẹ con chèo tuyền, giá xong tấm.
Trong quá trình, gì chuyển thì chức tuyền không mai bị lực khiến cả một người sẽ xuống nước.
Đến quỡ giá chêu.
Một số người tại xá xân kim một phát hiện có người đang bị đối nước,
đến hồ hoàn ứng cưỡ và báo chính quyền để phương.
Tuy nhiên, giá khu vực sẽ giá tên nặn nước xấu và phát hiện mỗi nên cả bốn hạn nhân đều đã thiệt mạc.
Vụ viện thương tâm để lại đổi mất mắt lớn với gia đình nặn trên
và cũng để lại bại hòi phép giá, đến với cơ đối nước,
luôn hiện thủ nhất là trong những ngày hệ nặn.